there's a 10 10 minute sequence of the
film which has been people's biggest
reaction probably to the film took 90
minutes for these little to kick
in we really worked really hard on this
Quaalude sequence
and the thing about the losers we had a
drug advisor a drug counselor I I can't
I could put a few words in there myself
yeah you know Donny's addicted to a
variety of different drugs and she kind
of walked me through what the effects
were of each one on your body and how
you would physically move your body if
you were on them
she said like your finger would weigh
like 10 pounds basically I thought of it
as there was like a little version of me
having the inside of me having to lift
my entire body around
it was probably the most wild thing I've
ever done in my entire life Jonah Hill
and I looked at each other how we
allowed to get paid to do this for a
living it was just insane because it's a
real story the biggest thing that
surprises you at the end is that these
guys are still alive